your model I am a beautiful city you
know you know Brad painted Jim Carrey
so he sort of controls this part of the
neighborhood because sit down the woman
wants to see me yeah hello ladies
I can't see you but you can see me my
name is Peter Santaniello
and weren't peshawar one of the coolest
places on planet Earth good morning guys
here in Peshawar Pakistan city of 2
million people and the KPK which is the
Northwest Frontier Province Peshawar is
the oldest city in Pakistan from 539 BCE
and it seems like everyone's come
through here at one point in time the
Greeks the Persians the moguls the Brits
Afghanistan 50 K that way
the center of this sprawling metropolis
over here nice by you professor why
this is help for me it's better for me
to rest
good on you thank you brother guy so you
don't mind taking me down to the center
sure those up is off no problem I'll
drop you off have you ever been on one
of these things before on the back of
this super bike yeah I know that right I
have not that's a free medicine or sick
[Music]
I hold on here
to the ride but it so guys wasn't one
question for you there's a lot of
security chuckling that ring
yeah it's all good but they still have
the
moorthi
they just want to be careful that's it
it's not like it used to be told
years ago there was a lot of things
years ago there's a lot of things going
on right
it's all good I saw Satan and you get to
have all they give me food I don't know
whether you've had before yeah they're
boots good
I have no had a Pashtun again
I yearn for shower now this is the real
deal you have to try postal gotta go man
I do take care
[Music]
you say yes
yes how long I just got I mean that my
first experience was that motorcycle and
to hear that's it but I stayed two more
days
how crazy is that
just got out of the hotel saw the guys
on the bike started talking this they
said you know if we can give you a ride
into the center
and that's how it started
thank you my name well I'm done hey well
waited night
country for you my skies USA America I'm
showing my California Nevada California
danger host and very nice Boston Austin
okay friends see you next time thank you
so much Jay Baruchel
okay and now meal I want to take take us
to the old city right yes who's this
famous actress called we're about a
grouping sold chickens other beef
flowers looks like a desert right
[Music]
some little fritter things dates it's a
food city huh yeah this is the foots it
feels good
good to see beans ago that dick and
Bobby here
food
how do you talk good oh thank you
thinking
they are giving way to the pupil right
they are not blocking this way I love
how this light just sort of filters
filters in use it that timeless hello
Emily colonics alone so I've heard you
guys were friendly
I've heard you guys heard friendly but
this is like a whole another level of
friendliness I think yeah giving you
feel of giving your love
and thank you this is the center of the
shower I will go to I don't think I
don't think I'll have a problem meeting
people
I was told the Pashtuns are emotional
romantic warm hospitable people
but that they also know how to fight
when needed
if you look at the geography in the
history of the city they see why it is
pretty much the gateway into Pakistan
and the Indian subcontinent
don't know what this is you oh my foot
your model I have expensive six-night is
it because the eyes are the muscles or
both and there's so it's like you're a
clothing model you know you model
clothes this is a t-shirt an offender oh
gosh yeah yeah so this is an electrical
electrical box her way yeah Oh cameras
Wow
Wow look at this architecture guys this
is beautiful
no English speaking yeah but you're
doing great look at this sorry I don't
speak Bastion yeah you're that door oh
my god how many stories have gone
through that door it's one of these
places everywhere you look has some
detail like this we look above beautiful
lookouts Wow
you guys have a beautiful city do you
know that
look at this archway and this is just
some random alleyway kids are playing
marbles focus with the day is awesome
hello
just another beautiful door
okay buddy where are we going
it's my new friend we don't speak what's
your name your name huh Reb Navas
Peter Salam alaykoum America America
here and come to Pakistan
yeah that's look it is good I love it
here you guys are so cool alright guys
what are we doing now what are we doing
this right this way okay thank you
thanks for being so cool you guys are
awesome
bye bye if you want to ever feel truly
truly welcome as a human come to
Peshawar Salam alaikum making some bread
we got the neighborhood kids and then I
have all these friends thank you guys
okay we're gonna go further down the
rabbit hole I'm shutting the camera off
the ton because literally it's walk for
30 seconds and someone invites you in
and
just tons of hospitality it's
unbelievable because we are loving
people yet we're packed in what's it's
one system once I stopped at the camera
got all these cool people around you
guys are awesome Salam alaykoum guys
wouldn't we got some cricket going on I
got to bounce it first right lloyd
ylenne leave our Ghana thanks rather a
great cameraman where we going take me
sir thank you guys there's a what areas
senior and Peshawar it's famous for its
hospitality hospitality and he's the
senior elder which means he is sort of
like the manager the mayor so he sort of
controls this part of the neighborhood
the ayah and he has a lot of respect
where we going how do you mean
women would like to see you okay okay
the woman wants to see me yeah yeah it's
my home but they're gonna look at me
through the through the screen okay I
can't see them so what am I supposed to
do look here hello ladies I can't see
you but you can see me yes Peter
Santaniello
how do you find if not love it so
cool really cool and I'm really loving
the Pashtun people really it's my first
day in Peshawar will you come again
yes inshallah and what is your name
someone tell me about yourself you live
here obviously I am Christian yes thank
you thank you this Christmas a man
forgot it's terrible mission I'm just
having too much fun here it's really
amazing I've had I've met like 300
people in an hour
thank you thank you so much it's your
sister okay is she as cool as you
she sounds it look at this to to great
the racer this guy really takes care of
it it's got the penguin on the penguin
on the seat it's very nice good style
sir if so our culture we always take
after the lunch tea green tea yes we
it's a green tea but weak kava kava kava
I wish you Christmas Merry Christmas
thank you it's an historic bazaar for
shower there are three buzzer there okay
this is one of what you see you will say
markets markets bazaar
is Muhammad is much
my name is mother kidding my name is
Muhammad late
my name is Peter Centinela and word
Peshawar one of the coolest places on
planet Earth
he looks like a cross between Brad Pitt
and Jim Carrey you know Brad Pitt and
Jim Carrey okay famous actors yeah I've
seen a lot of blue eyes here and a lot
of green eyes yeah very much big night
is it because so many powers have come
through here right so many people have
come through over the years yeah
Peshawar it's impossible to be alone
introduce yourself sir my name is Heidi
in from the show nice to meet you look
mine from Peshawar Junaid home to show
mr. Peter from Paris to you here
guys where are we going we are going to
straight to be so funny buzzer bizarre
to the field okay
I heard the food here in Peshawar some
of the best right and some of the best
in Pakistan it's yahood City it's to
food city but I was told that in Lahore
ter they said everything everyone said
it was a food place done is a beautiful
why did they why do they import spices
why did they put spices from the
subcontinent it's a food place it's a
food place with a lot of taste with a
lot of different things we don't create
haste there ain't nothing to waste
Indian Pakistan are the food place
that kills the rot the rap though
[Music]
so I'm gonna go
females some traditional food yeah
Israeli and some Czech know how that
chubby looks good yeah
is there any oil in the cry it looks
like this young lady forgot the oil a
little bit no that's a common common
Fisher look Evan but there's like this
very communal feel in everything there
yeah I felt it on the streets today
everyone knew each other on the studio
all the neighborhood's kids knew each
other look I'm a bit debility here today
it gives you diabetes so much are you
guys afraid of westernization coming in
change
maybe history up yeah
some of summer and some amazing so me
about promoting right that's why it's
funny
it's next oh yeah it's what we're time
back so again if you if you if you
everyone at talks its western mode of
living you lose everything that you have
into special which is special but if you
don't adopt some of it is that a problem
- yeah what is it like the answers of
course it is a problem because people
who will just cling on to the old ways
right which are a bit crude and
old-fashioned not really good for the
new world for the newer one that wants
to change for the better we should adapt
to some of it some of its ideas no it's
sculpture
[Music]
yeah the race where he had the food
yeah it's called the kiss of Pawnee
buzzer ha ha storytellers market ok so
people from the Silk Road people on the
Silk Road right over here and have some
green tea con cava and they would enjoy
the team and they would tell stories
teacher defies call this fruit market
just
telling your stories we're doing
something that there are this
so it's all gemstones here guys huh this
whole this whole area Salam alaikum
from where
what Moline tourmaline from Afghanistan
yeah
Paulie for woods with stone ax says let
me get swollen Wow do tonight
beautiful
the guy's scared they ganged up and
attacked me you guys got violent tried
to give money I tried to give money and
pay for this one better
this one is three dollars here but if it
was in the Western market
[Music]
if your cough is another drink
love this call bit prayers it's not it's
very very spiritual relaxing I sort of
find every laughs I mean it sounds of
distress oh these are the raw form of
the stones whoever wants a bit of
adventure in life and to go to a place
that's mystical it's mystical it's
beautiful and full of warmth Peshawar
until next one like and subscribe if you
want to support this channel hit the
notification Bell to be the first to see
my next video many more videos about
Pakistan and other parts of the world
coming soon